A brand new space pirate character has beef with
Greef in the latest episode of "The Mandalorian,"
but the man behind the mask is an industry
veteran. Here's what Vane looks like IRL.
Season 3 of "The Mandalorian"
offers up another glimpse into
the lives of Pedro Pascal's Din
Djarin, the ever-adorable Grogu,
and plenty of other returning characters, but
it also adds quite a few fresh faces to the mix.
Among the newcomers is an intimidating space
pirate named Vane. A frequenter of the Nevarro
locale, Vane doesn't take kindly to the new
direction of the city after its liberation
from the hands of the Empire. He's also
clearly got a history with Greef Karga,
a plot thread that seems ripe for
expansion in the series' future.
It was your cut of my boss'
treasure that built this saloon."
Beyond his plot significance, the most striking
thing about Vane is his physical appearance. The
space pirate's face is quite striking, lacking
any discernible nose and sporting horns not too
dissimilar from those on Darth Maul. It's such an
out-there appearance that viewers may be shocked
to learn what the actor behind Vane looks like
when he's not buried under heaps of prosthetics.
The man who plays Vane is Marti Matulis,
a 6-foot-4 American actor known
for his creature work in horror,
fantasy and science fiction. Matulis has appeared
in a bunch of popular TV shows for decades, though
almost invariably as characters that require
heavy prosthetics or elaborate costume design.
Back in the sixth season of "American
Horror Story," Matulis recurred as the
sinister Piggy Man — a ghost that
sports the giant severed head of
a pig. He appeared as several different
monstrous characters on "Teen Wolf," and
he's occupied a similar role for the
Paramount+ supernatural drama "Evil."
One of the actor's most high-profile
appearances in recent years, however,
is his role in the 2022 horror film
"Smile." In the movie's climax,
when audiences finally get a brief glimpse at the
true form of the malevolent Smile Entity haunting
the characters, Matulis is the one who brings
the demonic mass of flesh and teeth to life.
All in all, Matulis is quietly one of the key
players in the modern landscape of horror and
sci-fi. If anything, his eventual debut
into the canon of "Star Wars" through "The
Mandalorian" was something of an inevitability.
It also means he gets to join the distinguished
club of actors who have appeared in both "Star
Trek" and "Star Wars" at one point or another.
On an episode of Daniel Scherl's
"Memories of a Moonbird" podcast,
Matulis went in-depth on how demanding roles
that require heavy prosthetics can get,
telling the host that he typically sports a shaved
head and face, to make for easier gluing. The
transformation often takes hours to complete,
and Matulis, of course, has a front row seat.
"I just sit in a chair looking into a
mirror as I watch these ridiculously
talented people build this creation on top of me."
Even once the makeup and materials
have been applied, Matulis has to
account for his altered physicality when
giving his performance. He told Scherl,
"I might have to put 30 percent more effort
into my angry face or whatever happens during
the scene. So, that's my time to figure
out how I can translate myself through
the makeup and make the makeup look
alive and not like a rubber mask."
It's tough work, but Matulis has nevertheless
stuck with the job for more than 20 years. As
major roles like Vane in "The Mandalorian"
and the Smile Entity in "Smile" demonstrate,
that commitment has paid off.
Matulis shared on the podcast,
"As a younger actor, I thought, 'Oh,
that's really cool but it's more of a
step to do something else.' Now, as a nearly
50-year-old kid, I adore this process."